hello chess fans hope you're having a
great
day or night whenever you are
we here are looking at another
three hours of fun with chess and
psychology
gmp she seems to be a little bit hyped
up he's
very very running around hunting stuff i
don't know what he's hunting
if you hear that right now he's hunting
a plastic bag
um i was looking at some karpov games
and i decided to
show a little bit of carp of love this
game was really cool
uh there was another cool game too but
i've recently shown well not recently
within the last few months i've shown
that
to my scholastic kids so i didn't really
want to
make overlaps in case any of them are
watching
but that game was also very pretty
pretty clean sacrifice this game is not
exactly coin sacrifice but
still cool enough all right
um hello hello
i'm seeing more people showing up
perfect
all right uh
let me just refresh my page to make sure
everything is good and ready
yep all right let's go ahead and get
started
so remember i per usual we
are going to be looking at a game
um if you're lucky too and then
switch it to twitch after about an hour
here
and we're gonna start analyzing your
game so if you have any games or if
you're considering playing any game
within the next hour
make sure to save that somewhere so
then we can go over those games together
alright well that being said
let's go ahead and start looking in this
lovely game so as you can see in the
title this is a carpo versus
a savon game and
let me just double check which year was
that oh yeah that was 1971.
uh yeah 1971 and
so uh yeah i believe that savon
was the that year's ussr champion and he
had higher
uh low or rating compared to karpov
and so that's probably
why we'll see in the game that um
carp of the carl's opponent savann
played a little bit more aggressive
um silva i think
the i believe the screen is not black
because i'm watching myself on youtube
too
that's how i kind of get your chats so
if you see my head going
around i'm not listening to breakdance
music which incidentally i would
actually like to listen to some music
but let's go ahead all right
so we got some cool roy lopez going on
oh she's going for his food which is
empty
he's on a diet and
all right so uh i believe this knight e4
is not exactly um
it is a little little on red let's see
if i can
lower it maybe a little audio uh
yeah it keeps going on red probably
because
i have my um laptop is
giving out some cool noises let me maybe
close in some applications see if that
helps
okay bye bye chess base no need for
chess base for now
see maybe i can get out of skype and
telegram too
probably a little better all right uh
let's get back to chrome
uh red lopez drawing less than 10 moves
not necessarily also keep in mind that
this was 70s
so the um the depth of the openings was
not
as high and as computer-ish
as it is today so okay
um yeah so so far so good we are seeing
a nice trend
and okay here actually is the first
position that i wanted to
uh question you guys so this is all
theory but
if so for those of you who play this
feel free to drop hints in the chat
of what white wants to actually what
black wants to achieve
how do you see this um next few move sk
lighting
yeah i recently started doing the move
escalate and i kind of find it
interesting enough i've had to write
so much application stuff oh my god it
never ends like
last five months of my life technically
six
i feel like i've just been writing
applications after applications after
applications
oh it's like the same thing but you have
to perfect it then you have to trim it
down
600 characters or less space included
then you can add more experiences then
you have to combine the experiences ah
yeah so glad to have you guys here so i
can vent slightly as well
hi
nope he did not want it
okay so any suggestions
so far i don't see anything in the chat
but if you can just you know give me a
little idea of
how do you see white's pieces developing
the future of these pieces
the future of these pieces probably it's
kind of a short castle so that's not the
deep question well where do you see this
bishop
i've actually been to saint petersburg
um
once yeah in 2015.
yeah i really liked it it was very
gorgeous
i don't remember i remember it was a
chagoran memorial
yeah so this bishop can be on e7 can be
on c5 that kind of depends i believe it
kind of depends on
how sharp black wants this game to be um
how about white where is white trying to
get his pieces out
so the one thing is like this knight c3
is a big no-no
this bishop here is not as useful as we
want it to be
so potential relocating
and i believe this idea of a4 in long
run could come in handy we're not
entirely sure about the bishop just yet
i'm assuming e3 looks pretty cool
uh let's see this light is the one that
i'm not
quite sure about where it's gonna go but
i mean in short term i think something
like this
but after that kind of like still up in
the air
yeah thank you and j fan well i'm gonna
quote one fact that's
uh about senator carpool is that he
always thought about
why his opponents made that move
yeah that is true
yeah this so i feel like this pushing
and this knight coming out of here and
this bishop probably going to e3
is a good start so let's just go so now
we have our first move c3
i think maybe bishop e3 is also possible
takes away the bishop c5 ideas
and then you can do this but um you also
have to realize whenever you do this
knight d2
this it's i guess it's also possible it
kind of
forces black to play bishop e7 but
you don't know when you want to play
this bishop e3 if you know for sure you
want to play bishop v3 right away then
do it
but tomorrow most of the time it's
easier to
start with c3 to kind of fix these pawn
movements
now with bishop c5 now you get your
night outs because no more bishop e3
right
now after getting a night out castle now
now what we don't exactly want to take
over here
because even if you try to do all this
cool stuff
it's not really going to be a good
choice because
at the end of the day that pawn is going
to be
or as best as i could make that sound
um how about bishop getting to e5
uh legally
so no i don't want to take that right
away but i'm
open to bringing more pressure on it
what do you think about that can we try
to bring in some pressure for here
knight to d from the end of that line uh
the e5 pawn is
still pretty weak
that's an issue that we can't just let
it slide by
hopefully
i like bishop c2 yeah i think uh bishop
c2
is like so the ideas of trying to get
rookie you want getting the knights
involved
all of this are valid but at the moment
this is better
just trying to activate the pieces that
we know how
is a better choice
sometimes it can be very very tricky to
make those decisions all right so bishop
c2
uh bishop f5 defending this night's
uh weaknesses now what
are we gonna take that
ideally we don't want to take that
ideally we want the choice to
still be present um and
we want to be able to actually develop
we don't want to just take stuff
especially because if we take an
opponent's um
pawn structure going to be much stronger
not really we don't want to take this we
take it he takes the pawn
even if we try to be all the ways like
cool we're just going to lose this pawn
if we try to take this first maybe
or if you just be like you know what
this is a nice pin i'm just gonna
develop my bishop
it's okay but bishop g6 black still does
hold um
holes not necessarily any advantage for
anybody but black just holds
we don't exactly want that
yeah knight b3 i like that instead of
taking just knight b3
we have more serious threats this is
pinned
me likey now bishop g6
now finally this knight d4 that was
suggested so
much earlier keep in mind taking on here
is not exactly ideal because it simply
take and then take over here
that's free bishop so after an id4
uh black simply took white takes and
black went for a5
now this move might seem a little
aggressive and
it's a good idea to keep in mind that
yes
black does want to try to win this game
because as i mentioned earlier
black is the one who is a little bit
upper hand because of the rating and
current ussr champion back in 1971
so knowing that it makes sense that
black is trying to you know be
um be more
i don't say active more maybe hopeful
try its chances yeah i think that's a
better wording
yes fishy i understand you're not a big
fan of this position
all right so after a5
what do you think white should do
removing the defender um yeah i like
that we got rid of this bishop honestly
this is a cool outpost too but the main
question is shall we take this
i don't it's a little fuzzy on whether
or not we should take this at least at
the moment there is no need to take it
i'm not sure if you heard that but that
would be his
royal highness meowing a little what do
you want
i think it's a little bored sometimes it
just gets bored and there's nothing i
can do about it
just has to work through it
i like the suggestion of trying to push
for a4
maybe not right now because a4 you also
give up this b5 square
before square
what about your bishop what do you think
we should do with this guy
bishop to g5 i mean ideally
but they're a bunch of stuff trying to
eat it so no no
no not yet at least
oh angry kitty
yeah i like bishop e3 normal simple
you're trying to
attack this i'm gonna defend it if you
try to push for a4
now then i can just go back to c1 and
come from a different angle
easy pc
in the game um black just went for
knight b4
we like this bishop we're going to keep
this bishop now he went for a4 now
what shall we do with this knight we
have three potential choices
what do you guys think should where you
guys think this knight should go
c1 c5 d2 well those are the three
choices
so i think c1 would be interesting
honestly trying to get to d3
however karpov chose knight to d2
and because this knight has been pushed
around
so long it's a little just frustrating
honestly
now i feel like knight c1 could have had
more interesting ideas but after a3
then you would have to kind of play like
b3 and then
c5 can come along black gets a lot more
active than
i'm comfortable with so i like this
knight d2 because it keeps some pressure
on this position instead of just letting
black do whatever
he wants so
knight d2 and here black went for a3
now what do we do with this guy shall it
be take
shall we push should we defend it let's
see how let's see like
so let's say these are my three choices
what do you think we should do and
peachy meowing is not one of them
come on boy
ah queen bee tree no i don't
think betray simply because take take
and then this knight can just go back
and this is weak
pieces are very very unorganized i don't
like that
um how about queen c1
i don't like b3 either because just
knight c3
you got to move this queen let's say you
go to f3 and then this can't fall you
take that and then like bc2 can come up
no no
so b3 is off
take somewhere between taking and queen
c1 i see
so
so we're i'm not i mean i feel like
taking might
also maybe but first of all take with
the rock
is an issue now because when you take
with the rock
this knight c3 still exists so let's say
you play queen c1
now the queen can just jump before
behind this
and black does i think black is much
more comfortable in this position than
white
is
does it how do we like that do we agree
with that
because black does feel quite more much
more comfortable honestly
so let's go back so we're only kind of
left with one choice of queen
c1 we are simply defending this poor guy
but yeah um
we're we still honestly do want to take
this given the choice
so let me ask you what do you think is
the best move for black
it's not taking because it takes just
the queen takes and everything kind of
feels
very wobbly this queen on the queen side
is very good
then we can also choose to do like a
knight b3
or even like a pawn push we have a bunch
of different stuff to do
so what do we think
no not that's the result i think the
short k6 is quite interesting
but i don't think it's the best one i
think maybe knight takes d2 would be
more interesting
then the queen would have to take it and
then you would try c5 because if now you
take it
then knight can go back and start
dreaming about stuff
all right i think 92 would have been the
most
interesting or weird one for us
but we were quite i don't
say lucky probably just um
better prepared yeah let's go with that
we were better prepared on this
and didn't really allow that you know
mind games i'm kidding uh
why does the queen have to take the
knight well if you take it to the bishop
it's possible but then like d3 could be
annoying and then you take this
take that and then you'd have to play
with rook
now bliss black has a little bit better
momentum
kind of wins that area you could take
now you could bring your queen in
getting
involved there's a lot of more um
more uh
i feel like it's more out there
yeah all right so yeah well black ended
up doing rook
a6 now what should we do is it time for
us to consider
taking or should we take something else
in the center what do you guys think
so
so
uh kicking it with f3 is not exactly the
move because
you can make sure to think what black
wants what do you guys think black wants
right now
there is this kind of a simple-ish idea
that black really wants to do
what do you think that is
telling you black doesn't have something
quite interesting
anything anything to attack potentially
i guess i need one to attack
yeah exactly rook c6 and this queen is
going to be in the pickle because if you
move it
then whoops if you don't move it well
you can't exactly block it like bishop
c2 e
none
so queen c1 rk6 now we know wider k6 was
played which we should have known
previously but hey better late than
never
now what
what do you think we should do as white
yeah i think it's time to take this it's
getting too dangerous now
um rooks d6 we gotta go up there
and black played knight c2 what do i
think about this
keep in mind taking it is possible but
it will result in light taking over here
if you take this
then rook can take it over here if you
decide
to take this oh no no no if you decide
to take this guy
then knight f1 could happen and black
does
hold um hold the
equality i wanna good chances let's go
with that i don't like the word equality
yeah black does hold pretty good chances
so knight c2 now what should we do
so
ah rook c one interesting why do you
think rook c1
okay trying to pin it okay i can live
with that
um
let's see
anything else you are considering
kind of like a one last tour before we
move it on
all right uh queen b5 i think could be
interesting
if it wasn't for rook b6 because now
when rugby sticks
your queen feels too out there and then
this can happen
and then you take that and then this
happens and then this is under attack
and if you take it
he can just take it a rock and then the
group goes over there and
uh so many things yeah i don't i don't
really like that
so i don't like queen b5 but i do like
trucks t1 so good job with rook c1
um now after district c1
we played sorry black can play take
now taking on a1 doesn't make as much
sense because we just take it over here
and this is also falling
so taking on c3 just makes more sense
because take now black thought that
there is a cool tactic here and he took
over here
what do you think is this working for
black
does this feel like this is working for
black
what do you think white should do now
hello irving
yep
uh taking on g6
not necessarily possible but not
necessarily
[Music]
it is y2 yes i feel like it
the problem is that taking there is this
knight d1 so that's the one
kind of like only thing to be mindful of
khan grabbing with queen b5
yeah questionable mainly due to if you
keep this knight here it's just going to
keep on
um in farsi it's like we have a good
expression like
as pikachu of techno but like it's like
kind of like
um kicks you with his back back legs
but i don't know how to translate that
actually if any of my frc people here
can translate that i would appreciate it
yeah exactly thank you essa how do you
translate that
yeah i'm having a little translational
issues
all right but yeah that's kind of the
general idea we can't we need to get rid
of these pieces
quickly so if we can take them what else
can we do with them
oh torn on your side i guess that could
work honestly
thank you yeah knight f1 to trade this
bad boy
these knights are too strong if i can
take them the least of all i can't
exchange them
all right i like this yeah i think this
is the best way to go about it
now in the game uh black actually played
queen d7
we took over here he resigned
because uh this game was kind of very
carp of style because white kind of
destroyed opponents with a series of
very quiet moves i really like that idea
and especially on the back rank so i
remember like this quincy one this roxy
one this knight f1 all of these cool
ideas
yeah they were pretty cool all right um
i am gonna take a second load a
carp of whoa oh no no no no no
uh load the carpool style
puzzle because we finish this
slightly faster than i oh
intended alright
so this puzzle is extremely famous so if
you already know it
no problem uh but if you don't that's
okay
that's why we're here if you already
knew everything then we wouldn't need to
get together right
oh
um honest give me a minute
i'll go back to it after this this one's
done
sorry kind of jumped it
jumped the gun jumped it oh it is carp
of time so let's enjoy
this cool carpool game well um position
it's more of a like this game is very
soon
gonna be wrapped up
honestly most of the time i agree
resigning is not necessarily the best
course of action
but there are times that you're just
like uh i'm doing this
so if you can pull that off
actually
any suggestions for this one this is our
beloved carpool
we can do this come on guys
ah f5 i think is interesting
but i'll give you a little hint
f5 is something that can come up later
but training rooks
so do you mean we take it or do we kind
of persuade the opponent to take it
yeah rook d6 to persuade remember
outposts usually
are uh very much desired for
the nights but right now our mind can't
get there doesn't mean we can't use it
for other pieces
also i'm very much digging this cup
so far i thought i could only use it for
cold stuff but i recently erased not
like and i also use it for
hot beverage so
i also did something bad very very bad
i made the mistake
of treating myself to a ginormous box of
30 different flavored tea oh
i've been doing like two tea bags a day
it's very
addictive
yeah we do like our tea that is true
yeah i got all these different flavors
from a russian i believe
um tea company greenfield i've
i remember them since i was in russia
they had very few
memorable teas that i've been ordering
amazoning
since forever but i've after i saw i got
all a's that was kind of my treats i got
myself
a big box of chocolate and big box of
tea
i actually got a big box of coffee too
but that will arrive next month
yeah so that's not a problem see thank
you actually
knight c8 is the wrong and i want you to
tell me why knight c8 is wrong
and i see it as like very very wrong
okay um yeah exactly rick c6
and if you take i'll just take that
and i'll be eating this however
if you decide to not play like night
night ca
then if you just take it i would simply
take back and
then i kind of like converted this
advantage of having an outpost to having
a past pawn and an
open file and now f5 is coming up so if
you decide to go something like
maybe queen d7 now i have options such
as
knight a5s to attack over here
or i kind of also like trying
at five knights goes away the knight c5
if you take it then i'll take over here
now this is a weak one that's gonna fall
so yeah that was another one i
am a little hesitant on showing this
next carpool game
but we have time so i'm gonna take a
second to load that as well
yeah today we're doing more than we
usually do i like it
what about this one and for those of you
who
are interested i can share the link fun
leeches with you
after the class
i do have a microphone is my voice still
coming a little shaky
oh i wanted to i was supposed to address
something in the last one oh
uh too late sorry
i will do it right after this one
i was excited to share more games oops
yeah of course i'll i'll be sure to
share the link
as soon as we are done here
because i remember how frustrating it
can be like you know the position but
you don't remember exactly where you've
seen it so
it is white to move black has just
played
this rook the g8
and this move 40 so actually i don't
know if there was extra time on
40 let me read into this
white does have pretty cool space
advantage on king side right
but everything in like black camp seems
to be
in order to
there's only one open file there's a
good fight going on along it
i think something like f6 could be
interesting to consider
these are the moves to be aware of
but they're also gonna expose white's
king not just black's king
so
let's see what else i think this knight
could
this pawn could also be a nice target
for the
knight but not at the moment at least
the moment that does not seem very
likely to be happening
[Music]
no this is not the time to push pawns
not nope nope not the time
maybe in a little bit it will be time
but not right now right now that is not
the time
moving king nope not that i'll give you
a hint it's
it's not a king move or a rook move i'll
give you that hint
alright let's see if i can drop any
other hands without giving up
the move so if i try to open up the
queen side he's just gonna play a5
either
trying to attack this bunch of times is
not exactly the right way too so don't
try to move the nitros yet
so now the question is what if we try to
combine all three of these ideas
trying to combine opening up the king
side
opening up to attacking on c5 and
potentially this a3
so we want to do stuff on h file queen
slide and that f6 g6 idea
how can we combine them all bishop h5
interesting but not exactly
not the right move for the bishop if you
play bishop h5
i think something like f6 might be
unpleasant but
it looks pretty good i agree
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna probably
give you guys another minute it's not
queen b2 you're going the wrong way with
the queen
that should kind of give it up but yeah
did i give it up completely
so the move is indeed queen d1 we're
gonna try and bring the queen to the
queen to the king side
while still maintaining that cruel
relationship
with the kings with the queen side so we
want
we want it all we want the kings out we
want the queen side we are being
very greedy right now and that's good
why not we deserve it yeah so queen d1
is the best one and then we're gonna
follow it up with
so here black played um king d8
now as white we are going to continue
honestly here something like queen g1 is
also
pretty cool and that's actually what um
white play 2 because
remember this idea of attacking or on c5
is something that we considered
and we kind of thought about it with
queen going to f2 previously but now
looking at it deeper with queen on g1
what do you think about that
anything from here
too deep i agree it's a little too deep
okay so queen even better than queen d3
because stroke exchange question um
no queen d one is better because we want
to get the queen to the queen side
to the king side yeah so we got the coin
to the king side
now what
not right now with sub h5
but so it goes mainly because it's um
white it's black to move now black
played this knight b6
the thing is that um karpov
doesn't necessarily need to stay on the
back rank so now
he can try and double slash triple step
up in the king
in this super cool file so that's
another
idea so now
um queen works to e7 trying to
still keep this over here maybe knight
goes back to defend it if need be
finally knight b3 bringing more stuff to
attack this
uh queen h1 would have been okay too but
then there's like queen f8
take take and black
black kind of got this file we don't
necessarily need to give it up and i
don't think
we should so let's keep the tension so
knight b3
and king c7 now
how can we um where do you think is the
best place to put the king to be able to
get the queen involved here
king g3 yeah
[Music]
not exactly
f3 yeah let's go to f3 king g3 i think
that
the issue is that i just
it just i don't like that my king can be
so vulnerable
that bugs me i don't think there is any
like logical
like move-wise like if i do this he's
gonna do that i don't think there's
anything
it's just like the fact that there are
different things
working against my king really does bug
me
so let's not do that
king f3 now we are attacking this
by three stuff he's only defending it by
two so he brings the knight to defend it
by
three so let's keep
let's take a look at this position and
then go back and take a look at the
initial position
if i can click on it come on let me
click on it
so what do you think has changed
this king kind of run over up here we
got the knight a little higher we got
the
rook a little more involved and the
queen a little bit to the
um queen side to king side right
a5 can't be played fair point the other
rook
still not participating i agree with
that
so remember one of the plans that we had
at the beginning
was to try to do this a3 but the problem
was a5
thank you sydney yep a3 now after
a3 since there's no more a5s this is
going to be good for us because the king
just came up here so opening up
this side is good take and now what do
we do
keep remembering the king is in the
queen side so now we want to do stuff in
the queen slide
so we got to bring our pieces how do we
get our pieces in the queen side
immediately
hi brian yeah rocket too there we go
and after this rocket 2 our idea is that
we are just going to keep
pressure over here and
this rook hitch 2 was kind of cool
because we got to swap it to the queen
side
now black draws a drinkage 4 but we eat
it over here
then black tries to play like
rocket j but that doesn't exactly help
either we can simply just bring the
stroke over here
now knight a5 coming up too if you try
to bring it back
now what do we do now what piece can be
improved
these two are cool this bishop is eh
okay can't really do much with it this
bishop is good this knight is good
what piece can we bring around
yep queenie one oops ah yes queen e1
oh wrong way so after queenie one
we get the chance to get this queen
involved as well
uh black was just like yeah this is too
gone he took over here
thank you he played bishop c8 check and
he resigned
even if you try something like rook b6 i
have a cool
little tactic take i can take this
you take it back i'll just take over
here and
this is super winning if you take it to
the bishop
now i can take take and just c5 it's
kind of a massacre
yep how does that look everybody happy
well i guess black's not happy but
everybody except for
the player who played this game is black
everybody happy
all right if everybody is happy we are
gonna take a short break
and do our segment of switch to twitch
and i'm gonna go refill my tea make sure
everything is set for twitch
i'll see you guys i'll see everybody
there in about 10
maybe 15 minutes and yes we're gonna do
the analyzer games yep
i just need more fuel and i need to hug
his majesty gmpg for a minute
yeah all right everybody i'll see you
soon uh make sure to have your games
ready
meet me there in 10 ish minutes and
what's twitch oh
uh let me also figure out how to share
this link
cause i um
let me type this in here leeches.org
slash study
slash
all right let me know if this link works
if not i'll share it more
but yeah um join us on twitch twitch is
another platform that we
frequently stream on if you haven't seen
us there make sure to do it so
we stream uh much more frequently on
twitch i believe
uh link of twitch just go on twitch and
look for stl
chess club
yeah make sure to go on twitch and look
for steal chess club
and all right guys i'll see you there
shortly have a great rest of your
evening